okay why don't we get started since I
had some problems at the end of last
lecture I'm gonna pick up all right
where things got a little dicey too last
lecture and we're gonna start over so
we're looking back at figure 7 3 which
if you remember was the cost curves for
our cost function 10 plus 5 Q squared
remember we came from this cost function
we derived ourselves from the production
function and wages and rental rates we
derived this cost function we're now
graphing the cost curves that come out
of this cost function and we're talking
about profit maximization and we talked
about measuring profit remember so we're
talking about perfect competition
perfect competition and remember we said
that profits are revenues minus costs
that means the profits per unit our
revenues per unit minus cost per unit
revenues per unit our price and cost per
unit is average cost so profits for you
per unit is price minus average cost so
let's go to the diagram you see the
height of the profit rectangle is price
minus average cost okay
so what do you do you start by finding
the point so what are your steps here
step one is you find the point where
price equals marginal cost that gives
you your production level that gives
your optimal Q star we derived that last
time of three okay we derive that last
time that you want to you want to
optimize the point where price equals
marginal cost
that gives our Q star of three then at
that level we compute average cost
average cost at Q of three is simply
going to be this cost function divided
by three so 10 over 3 plus five times Q
squared over plus five Q squared over
three are just five Q plus 15 okay so
the average cost at three is going to be
eighteen point three three that's me the
average cost at production of three that
means that profits at that depth at the
profits were making for that third unit
the problems are third you
it is the price profits per unit are the
price which is a fixed level of 30 - the
average cost which is 18 point 3 3
so profits per unit equals 11 point 6 7
so that's the profit that's the height
of the rectangle the profits per unit is
11 point 6 7 the price - the average
cost is 11 point 6 7
we're selling 3 units so that means our
total profit rectangle is 35 ok so our
total profits are 35 which is 3 units at
a profit of 11 point 6 7 each ok and
that's how we get that rectangle
questions about that okay so now let's
return to what we did last time let's
imagine there's a tax of 10 dollars per
unit okay that would shift the cost
curve to C equals 10 plus 5 Q squared +
10 Q remember it's a tax per unit plus
10 Q okay that would mean so that is
illustrated in Figure 7 for okay that
means that the marginal cost curve and
the average cost curve both ship up
shift up marginal cost is now equal to
10 Q plus 10 okay we want to set that
equal to the price to get the optimal Q
and you solve this and you get a new Q
star equals 2 so now your optimal
production level is 2
okay you set your new marginal cost
equal to the price margin cost equals
price marsh particles priced at a new
quantum quantity of two what's the
profits there well once again profits
profits per unit are just price which is
30 minus average cost what's the average
cost to 2 the average cost of 2 is going
to be 10 over Q so 5
10 over 2 is 5 okay +5 Q because we're
dividing this by Q 5 Q which is 10 okay
plus 10
okay 30 minus 25 which equals 5 so your
profits per unit the height of that
rectangle has fallen from eleven point
six seven to five so you're now making
less profit per unit and you're selling
fewer units the height of the rectangle
is shrunk the width of the rectangle is
shrunk so your total profits have fallen
from 30 to ten okay used to make profits
of eleven point six seven in each of
three units now you make profits of five
on each of two units so that taxes
lowered your profits from 30 to ten okay
question about that yeah yes exactly
because you have a higher cost now it's
not just that your cost change if your
cost changing fed through to your
production as well so because your cost
change you produced a different level
and you made a different profit per unit
okay all right now let's go to the other
point I tried to cover last time though
I only get straight on which is the
shutdown decision now remember we are in
the short-run shutdown we're in the
short run and the short run there's no
entry and exit the firm can't literally
leave but it can just produce zero that
would call the short-run shutdown
decision
oh sure we're shut down decision you're
still in the market you still paid your
fixed costs you just produce zero that's
mean by shutdown as opposed to exit
which is literally take your toys and
leave this is you're still in the mark
you've paid your fixed cost you can't go
anywhere
remember those costs are fixed in the
short run but you just produce zero so
now let's ask for example what happens
if the price suddenly dropped to ten
let's say the price dropped from 30 to
ten well you're the fundamental profit
maximization rule never changes the
profit Max's inlet we're not having the
tax anymore we're back to the original
our original cost function so there's no
cost function see you
10 plus 5 q squared okay
so the marginal cost equals 10 Q and our
profit max is a shoe rule does not
change a profit maximization rule is
that price equals marginal cost
so we set 10 Q to 10 marks cost equal to
price 10 is the price and we get to the
optimal quantity is now 1 okay we now
want to produce one unit that's the
optimal quantity well what is our
profits if we produce one unit we'll
profits equals revenues 10 minus costs
well what's our costs if we produce one
unit 10 plus 5 15 so profits are
negative 5
okay I'm going fast so jump in if I get
the math wrong here okay profits are
negative 5 so you might think that's
terrible using money you should get out
of there shut down but the answer is as
we discussed last time you should not
shut down because shutting down still
means paying your fixed costs no matter
what you do you have to pay those fixed
costs so shutting down means production
of zero
what are your profits at a production of
zero your profits at a production of 0 R
0 revenues minus the fixed cost of 10 if
you produce 0 what's your cost plug 0 in
here your costs are still 10 so if you
produce newer your profits or minus 10
so you should continue to sell even
though you're losing money even though
you're losing money you continue to sell
that one unit you don't go to zero okay
because that's zero you're even worse
off this is the key thing about
short-run shutdown decision yeah
ah but that's the key thing once you
move to the long run you can reoptimize
your capital and you can exit but in the
short run you've already paid that
you've already laid down your blanket
which cost you ten you might as well
sell it a loss if you just sell zero you
then you've laid down your blanket for
ten and got nothing out of it okay
that's the transition to the long run
okay so basically and so basically
that's how you think about the short run
ders the long run so what do we think
about how this works so basically the
shutdown rule the way to think of the
math the shutdown rule is that basically
you only want to shut down if your
revenues are less than your variable
costs because you got to pay your fixed
costs no matter what that's done you're
in the short-run that's gone forget it
you laid your blanket down on the bazaar
that's done so you only want to shut
down if your revenues are less than your
variable costs you don't care about your
fixed costs that's done ulicia know that
if your revenues will lessen your
variable costs well that's the same as
saying you only want to shut down if
your price variable costs rpq I'm sorry
your variable costs you only shut down
if your price or less than your then
your average variable costs so divide by
Q you only shut down if your price is
less than your average variable costs
okay that's the shutdown rule shut down
if the price you get is less than on
average what you'll get for the unit for
the unit's you sell so in our example
you never shut down and why is that
listen to the math of our example well
in our example what our variable cost
the variable cost is five Q squared if I
put these down the variable cost in our
example variable costs are five Q
squared so what our average variable
costs five Q okay those are average
variable costs now remember that um you
want to shut down if variable costs are
greater than the price
we can express the price in terms of Q
because remember marginal cost equals
price so 10 Q equals P so at the optimum
it is always true that P equals Q over
10 that's a profit maximizing condition
okay that P equals Q over 10 we can just
substitute that in and we have that
average variable costs equals 5 times Q
so average variable costs equals 0.5
times P at the optimum okay because we
know what the outer marginal cost equals
price we can plug that in say at the
optimum average cost of 0.5 times P yeah
Q let me see if I got that wrong yes I'm
sorry Q equals Q equals P over 10 you're
right Q equals P over 10 my bad sorry so
the average variable cost is 0.5 times P
what's the shutdown rule the shutdown
rule is that price is less than average
variable cost or price is less than 0.5
price which can never be true
so you never shut down with this cost
function okay to say it again you only
shut down a price is less than variable
cuz then average variable cost we've
computed our general cost in terms of
price at at 0.5 times price therefore
you never shut down okay and you could
see this when we actually go to so you
can actually see this in Figure 75 when
we look at the firm's supply decision so
as figure 75 does is show you at every
price what the firm wants to produce in
the short-run at a price of 10 it wants
to produce 1 we showed you that at a
price of 20 it wants to produce 2 at a
price of 30 wants to loose 3 and so on
that - that that line that runs from 0 0
to 4 40 that's a marginal cost line okay
at each point price equals marginal cost
the alto production decision okay so
and you never shut down you always as
long as price is positive you produce
yeah
I'm sorry to understand price is always
above average variable cost so you'd
never shut down right that's a shutdown
rule this kid never this could never be
true with this function price is forever
above average for our cost you can see
that in this graph right
the price is Oh with the price equals
the marginal cost and that is always
above the average variable cost okay so
the bottom line is you never shut down
but here's the other cool thing after
all this confusing math guess what this
line is this marginal cost line what
else do we call that
that's a supply curve people we just
derived the supply curve what's the
supply curve the supply curve is the
relationship between the price and the
market and the amount of producer
desires to produce well that's what this
marginal cost curve is so we've just
shown you that the firm's supply curve
is simply its marginal cost curve so all
you need to know to derive what a firm's
supply curve looks like is what its
marginal cost curve looks like and
you're done so literally you take
production plus input prices and that
gives you the supply curve
why because production plus input prices
gives you the cost function to take the
derivative the cost function with
respect to quantity that gives you the
marginal cost function that's the supply
curve so just like I could give you a
utility function and a budget constraint
and you got the demand curve here I can
give you a production function and input
prices and it gets the supply curve
however only under perfect competition
okay this is only for the case of
perfect competition that's there's some
consumer theory that was in everywhere
rule because I've given you an extra
constraint which is a constraint on the
market I've allowed you to Rive the
supply curve just like we easily derived
the demand curve okay so we have now
derived a firm's supply curve okay
questions about that so let's go back
one more time
just like if I give you on say a problem
set or an exam a utility function a
budget constraint you should be able to
draw a demand curve if I give you a
production function and input prices
and I tell you in perfect competition
then you should be able to draw a supply
curve because it's just a marginal cost
curve okay now that's the firm's supply
curve what we care about actually in the
N is the market supply curve right I've
been doing little Q we care about big Q
that's what I drew in the first lecture
was a big Q diagram so how do we get
there well all you do to get the market
supply is to horizontally sum each firms
supply so we can see that in Figure
seven seven
okay what's figure seven seven does is
take multiple identical firms and put
them in the market so for example if
there's one firm in the market the
supply curve is what we just drew okay
at a price of ten you get ten at a price
of 10 you get one at a price of 30 you
get three now let's add a second
identical firm well that firm behaves
the same way at a price of ten it
produces one and a price of thirty it
produces three so the market now
suddenly has twice as much at a price of
ten it has two at a price of thirty has
six now let's add a third firm it
behaves the same way at a price of ten
it produces one the price of three
produces three so each additional firm
you add okay just literally shifts the
supply curve down okay so in other words
the point is that a market supply curve
as you add more and more firms the
market supply curve is always more
elastic than the firm's supply curve
because any given increase in price
calls forth from each firm an increase
in four in quantity and as long as
there's multiple firms that means a
flatter market supply curve than a firm
supply curve
okay so that's how we get the market
supply curve we solved for the firm's
supply curve we then just horizontally
sum it over the number of firms in the
market get the firm supply curve
horizontally some okay questions about
that now now we have everything we need
to go back to the first lecture back to
the future
okay back to the first lecture and we
can actually get to market equilibrium
in the first lecture we
started without supply curve and demand
curve and got equilibrium what we
derived the demand curve a few lectures
ago we've just derived the supply curve
so let's do short-run equilibrium
let's do short-run equilibrium okay
now the key thing is that so how do we
do short-run equilibrium let's go
through the steps step 1 each firm picks
a fixed amount of capital it's going to
have in the short-run okay so each firm
has a K bar okay and based on that it
has a production function either as a
production function - Q equals f of K k
bar L okay we and we have some input
prices we have some W and some are taken
together we can use those to create a
cost function which in our example with
C equals 10 plus 5 Q squared step one
step two okay um
step two based on this we can get
optimal production levels from the
fundamental profit maximization rule MC
equals P okay so this yields we know so
here we say ten Q equals P and this
yields a supply function which is Q
equals P over ten and that's our supply
curve that's what I drew here Q equals P
over ten is the firm's supply curve okay
that's step two step three is to create
a market supply curve well let's say
there's six firms in the market I'm just
pulled this out of thin air in a minute
we'll get to how many firms there are
but for now in the short-run
there's no entry and exit so whatever
number of firms I tell you that's what's
there let's just give it okay so let's
say N equals six let's say there's six
firms okay and I'll come in a minute to
where six comes from but for now let's
just assume it okay that means that the
total market supply big Q is just equal
to six little Q
six little q which equals 3/5 P okay or
6/10 P okay that is our market supply
curve yeah the number of firms that are
out there yeah but once again once
they're in they're done they know
there's six firms so they're done let me
I'm gonna come to this that's that you
talk about the long run okay
other questions yeah okay so that that
gives you your market supply finally we
go back to lecture 1 and the first
recitation where you saw mathematically
for equilibrium we have some domain
curve I'm just gonna make this up let's
say the demand curve is Q equals 48
minus P I just made that up to make the
math easy okay where does this come from
well you know where that comes from you
solve where that comes from
that comes from consumer maximization
okay 48 minus P so to get out the
Librium we just said 48 minus p equal to
3/5 P okay demand equal the supply and
we end up with P equals 30
conveniently familiar number okay which
means that the total demand big Q is 48
minus 30 equals 18 also convenient
number and I'll show you why the fifth
step each firm says given this price
what do I want to produce well we know
that given a price of 38 firms little Q
star is 3 right that's what we solved
each firms little Q star is 3 given a
price of 30 okay so each firm produces 3
units how many firms are there what six
times three supply equals demand six
firms brews three each at a price of 30
that's 18 at a price of 30 people want
18 equilibrium
that's how it all works so leaving aside
where the six came from everything else
you see here is just taking what we did
in working out the math and we get six
firms in the market the each one to
produce three that's the 18 that people
want okay so to get equilibrium you just
need a ought to get equilibrium you need
a demand curve
you need a cost function and you need
the number of firms in the market you
demand curve you need a cost function
and the number of firms in the market
given that you can get you can solve for
the equilibrium questions about that
yeah demand curve yeah q equals 40 minus
P is the demand curve okay other
questions
good questions there's a good clarifying
questions ok so now let's ask where the
hell six comes from okay
and where six comes from is the fact
what six comes from is from the long run
so now we get to long run to long run
competition which is in the short run
there's a certain number of firms in the
market but where those firms come from
well they come from the fact that each
short run is a repeated exercise that
makes up the long run so the number in
the long run perfect competition in the
long run
looks just like perfect competition the
short run full information no
transaction costs lots of firms with one
difference we're now going to allow
entry and exit nothing else is going to
change in the short run except we're now
gonna allow entry and exit ok so now
what and one other thing I'm sorry one
other thing changes since all costs are
variable there's no shutdown decision ok
there's no issue of this shutdown rule
ok there's no more fixed costs space if
you lose money in the long run you shut
down so always to worry about its
profits you don't have to shut this
extra shut so the short rule made an
extra shutdown condition you don't worry
about it not long run just worry about
if you're making money or losing money
in the long run if you're making money
you're in if you're losing money you're
out so now let's ask how that pins down
the number of firms in the market ok
this is complicated so the best way to
do it I think is an example ok
let's and think about our fun the
fundamental rule I want you to keep in
mind in the example easy with this rule
the simple rule is if there's profits to
be made you enter if this profits if
there's losses you exit and these two
things together imply the fundamental
rule of competitive equilibrium that in
the long run profits are zero because if
there's ever profit in the market firms
will come in as ever lost the market for
loop firms will exit and that process
will continue until profits are zero so
our fundamental conclusion is the
long-run equilibrium pettite of equi
Librium features zero profits
now let's see why let's go to figure
eight one I want to talk about the
computer that circuit the market for
personal computers
let's see you guys were born like what
years so you're now like eighteen so
you're born like 1990s it's about when
you guys are born okay
1990 was a very interesting time for PC
market you all grew up in a PC world not
a personal computer world and but
basically in 1990 we're in a very
different world we're in a world that
was dominated by giant mainframe
computers okay my graduation speaker
from MIT in 1987 was Ken Olsen the
chairman of deck which was the one of
the premier manufacturer of giant
computers he gave the worst [ __ ]
graduation speech you've ever seen okay
if you're ever giving us if you ever
become famous see a graduation speech
the number one rule is don't spend the
whole speech talking about yourself he
spent the whole speech talking about how
wonderful he was
how deck was everything and five years
later he was bankrupt okay so take that
Ken Olson that's why you don't give a
speech talk about how wonderful you are
okay what happened well let's talk about
what happened let's talk about the PC
market okay
God hope kennels doesn't watch this okay
let's let's talk about the PC market
okay let's talk about Dell who was an
early PC manufacturer and what we're
going to in figure eight one is gonna be
two side by side grass I'm gonna go back
and forth between them if I'm if you're
ever not cleared about which graph I'm
talking about stop me
but I'll try to be very clear because
you have to think about both these
graphs in tandem on the right hand side
is the market for PCs the market graph
on the left hand side is Dells cost
curves so the left hand side graph is
firm-specific dowel information the
right hand side graph is the market in
the short run we were at a position
where people wanted pcs and there
weren't many people making them pcs guys
these pcs were super cool um I guess you
guys would be on your on laptops at
everything now but like piece like a
desktop PC was like an amazing thing at
this point everyone wanted them there
weren't that many people making them
okay so at that point Dell could their
short-run
they're the short-run market cost curve
was sr1
and the demand was D okay that was the
shirt so we're starting on the right
we're gonna go from the right to the
left start on the right the initial
market in 1990 was a short run cost
curve sr one of the man curve of D act
that intersection the price was p1
meanwhile Dell in the short run had a
marginal cost curve such now shift to
the left hand diagram at a price of p1
Dell wants to produce little q1 pcs
marginal cost equals price right so find
the intersection that price Hood's
marginal cost curve once again this is
very important so stop me if I'm going
too fast fine with the price intersects
the marginal cost curve on the Left
Dell wants to produce a little q1 well
what's its profits profits are price
minus average cost wealth average cost
was way below that so Dell made this
huge profit of the lightly shaded
rectangle that was its profit because it
produced little q1 at little q1 average
cost was way below price that made this
lighted dot rectangle and profits now
what happens
other companies see this to say hey we
want in what happens as more companies
enter a market the supply curve flattens
your horizontally summing firm's supply
curve supply curve flattens as it
flattens you move from SR 1 to SR 2 so
now we're back on the right in the
market as more firms enter and let's
assume there are more firms identical to
Dell that's our perfect competition
assumption the each firm that enters is
sort of identical so more firms just
like Dell enter gateway and all these
guys start entering ok and you get you
shift to SR to a flatter curve that
intersects the demand curve at the new
price p2 now swift to the left-hand
diagram the price facing Dell Falls to
p2 but their cost function hasn't
changed there's still Dell there's still
the same underlying technology paying
the same wages and rental rates so now
at their marginal cost curve is the same
so at this new lower price their
production
rob's to little queue to their
production drops the little q2 and their
profits fall to the darkly shaded
rectangle pi/2 they make less money as
firms enter and this process will
continue until profits go to zero even
at pi/2 for another firm I forget where
the third PC firm was some other firm
will come in and say wait a second this
still money to be made I want to come in
and I'll keep going to profits go to 0
these are repeated short runs
so sr1 was a short run Dell made a ton
of money then we get to the next short
run gateway enters SR 2 is the new short
run gateway and Dell still make money so
the third period and other firms can
enter ok it's going to go to profits
equals 0 yeah yes absolutely
come to that those there's a large set
of assumptions on this but that's I
think of it once again think of like
Dell and Gateway selling their computers
on rugs in front of the Eiffel Tower
ok it's all the same just go you can
compare equally they're all the same
thing so it's that kind of market ok now
let's think about poor old IBM flip the
page IBM dominated despite Ken Olsen's
claims IBM dominated the main the big
computer market ok they were and so they
were initially on the right-hand side in
equilibrium with supply curve SR 1 ok
that intersected demand now we're on the
mainframe market so in figure 8 1 we're
in the PC market figure 8 1 is the PC
market figure 8 2 is the is the
mainframe market ok the mainframe market
they're initially at supply curve 1
which is very flat because there's lots
of firms making mainframes intersects
demand at a price p1 ok now we go to the
left well remember IBM has to produce
where its marginal cost equals price
that occurs at production level q1 at
production of q1 it is losing
money iBM is losing money it is losing
that entire rectangle the entire large
rectangle now does IBM exit it can't in
the short run but in the long run the
next period some firms will exit some
firms will say yeah we lost one in the
short run we're stuck but in the long
run we just don't think this is a
winning game in particular firms with
high fixed costs will exit they don't
want to pay those fixed costs again in
the second period they don't have to
build the new factory they're not going
to do it they exit yeah I told you I
can't tell you that it's just some
period of time more than a month less
than 10 years okay it's the period over
which capital is variable think of the
period of time for which you can build a
new plant to make PCs think of it that
way so it's it's years okay so basically
so what happens then somebody exits says
I'm Abba this I'm shutting down the
plant moving somewhere else
that deepens the market supply curve
because now fewer firms are in the
market as that deepens the supply curve
the new intersection of supply and
demand is at the higher price P - IBM
stayed in the market okay they just
built a new plant okay at p2 okay they
now produce on amount q2 and at that
combination they are literally zero
profit that's the point where marginal
cost equals average cost which is a zero
profit point why is that zero profits
it's zero profits because remember
profits are price minus average cost
West price marginal cost so in marginal
cost equals average cost profits are
zero okay should be able to see that
from the math we did before so what that
means is that basically when firms are
losing money they will leave and drive
profits from below zero toward zero so
in the making one in they enter and
drive froster above zero towards zero
when they're losing money they leave and
drive profits from below zero towards
zero okay what does that mean
that means that our long-run perfectly
competitive supply curve is in figure
eight
it's flat long-run perfectly competitive
market supply is flat at the price level
the market long-run supply is the point
where marginal cost equals average cost
or where supply equals average cost okay
and why is this this is true because
there any price above that point if any
firm tries to charge more than ten
they'll be driven out of business if any
firm tries to charge below ten they
won't make any money remember before I
said earlier you said well gee why don't
first somebody asked why firms just
coming to take the whole market this is
why because cost is upward sloping you
don't want to come and take although
market you'll lose money okay that's
quite firms they want the whole market
if marginal costs was flat then you
would then be undefined you would want
the whole market but you don't roger
cost is rising so you never want to
produce at a price above ten because no
one will buy from you you never want to
prove that a price below ten cause you
lose money
therefore supply is perfectly elastic at
a price of ten yeah
no no no what see it there's a lot of
assumptions under this but under these
assumptions you never make money long
because they shut down there are short
room periods so let's let's say what
happened was let's go back to figure 8 -
let's say that another firm shut down
the next period and suddenly IBM started
making money what would happen some
would enter and drive profits back to
zero so under the assumptions we've laid
out here profits are zero because in the
long run we've achieved cost
minimization firms minimize their costs
where marginal cost equals average cost
look at the average cost curve firms are
producing at the minimum the minimum of
average costs is where average cost
equals marginal cost that is competition
has forced cost minimization I'm just
doing all sorts of mind-blowing stuff
here for you guys you can take hours to
recover from this okay
competition forces cost minimization why
because competition forces each firm to
produce her price equals marginal cost
and it forces entry and exit until
marginal cost equals average cost
therefore it forces each firm to produce
at the most efficient point which is
where marginal cost equals average cost
because that is the point at where
average cost is minimized so under
competition in the long run every firm
is cost minimizing the prusik the
minimum of their average costs okay
and therefore the supply curve is
elastic and it's defined purely by the
minute of average costs that is if you
know here's a cheat okay if you know
you're in a perfectly competitive market
and I give you a cost function then you
know the I guess you still need to
demand function - if I give you a cost
function of man function okay you know
you don't need to know how many firms
are gonna be in the market you don't
need to know little n ok you know in the
long run profit is going to be zero so
long run firms are just going to produce
at the minimum of average cost you find
that use the demand to find the price
and you're done
okay so competition leads to cost
minimization questions about that okay
now you're all thinking well wait a
second we've got rich parents many of us
who make money in these businesses I
don't see zero profits there's a stock
market that's been booming where's the
zero profits buddy I don't see zero
profits okay well the answer is because
it's twofold first of all remember firms
can make money in the short run in this
model okay but that does explain the
stock market stock from you're supposed
to be forward-looking not months but
years and decades so firms really
long-run profit zero
why would stalks be expensive why would
people want to invest in these companies
and the answer is because these
assumptions are unrealistic that this is
an extreme version of the model that
delivers some nice intuition but doesn't
apply to the real world so I want to
take the last few minutes to talk about
the assumptions that we've made that
don't really work in the real world to
make this model work doesn't mean the
model is invalid we learn a huge amount
and the key lesson of this model is
competition pushes you towards cost
minimization compensate I always say
about these models is not delivering
sort of a level a level truth but a
directional truth the directional lesson
is this is why competition forces firms
towards cost minimization but firms
weren't actually necessarily get to zero
profits and there's three there's at
least three complications the first one
is limited entry I assumed that firms
could costlessly
enter an exit in this market okay but in
fact that might be hard because in
reality we have some costs which I
talked about last time we have some
costs or two times ago okay costs which
once paid can never be recovered and
therefore firms might say look I don't
want to get into this market because
it's not like I can get my fixed costs
back out next period so if my fixed
costs are building a building next pair
I can just sell that building
someone else but I fixed costs are going
to med school I can't sell that med
school degree
therefore if doctors aren't going
profitable in the long run I'd be zero
profit long run I'm gonna go be a lawyer
instead there are some costs and those
some costs create what we call barriers
to entry there are barriers to entry
that come from costs that are sunk in
the long run okay med schools but there
are other sorts of barriers to entry
okay take our vendor market even in
vendor markets are not perfectly elastic
one baron she could be they could come
in the night and steal your stuff and
beat you up if you try to enter the
market okay there's lots of reasons why
markets aren't quite entry and exit is
not costless and easy okay there's lots
of barriers to entry once there's a
barrier to entry this graph goes away
because go back to figure eight one okay
after in the second short-run
equilibrium we've got these small
profits this small dark gray rectangle
right we as a then told you another firm
would enter and squeeze those away but
another front will enter only if what
only under what somebody raises are
going to tell me under what condition
would that third fermenter yeah no not
perhaps a greater than zero that's in
the model that was true but in reality
what has to be true profits be greater
than what some costs raise your hand
people I'm gonna give you credit cuz you
raise your hand regardless of who yelled
out the answer I'm gonna sue Mew were
right okay some costs profits have to be
greater than the barriers to entry so in
the short run you enter profits are
greater than zero in the long run you
only enter if profits or greater than
the barriers to entry which might not be
true there's always some costs of
starting a firm okay so profit will
never really go to zero they'll only go
down to the barriers to entry okay so
that's problem one probably two with
this model problem two is firms may
differ I've assumed and this was raised
in one question I
zoomed identical firms here but in fact
firms differ and in particular different
firms have different cost functions and
with different cost functions you can
get some firms making long-run profits
so for example let's consider and figure
8 for the long-run sub market supply for
cotton this is from a textbook example
ok and this is from estimates that
people have made of the minimum of the
the minimum average cost of Bruce and
cotton by country so in other words this
is old now but it doesn't matter then
country names no matter the examples
what matters in the period of time this
study was done the cheapest place to
Bruce cotton was Pakistan you Bruce
cotton Pakistan for 71 cents per I don't
know kilogram 1002 cents per kilogram
okay however oh that was only for a
certain amount at some point Pakistan
ran out of cheap cotton and they had to
start preusse and cotton using more
expensive methods remember marginal
costs at some point is to slope up so
what is marginal cost was sort of flat
for a while in Pakistan then has to
slope up and suddenly it becomes cheaper
to Bruce cotton in Argentina at a dollar
eight
okay then Arjun and then it becomes
cheaper Bruce continent are Australian
of dollar fifteen and eventually if the
price gets to dollar 56 it's finally
cheap enough to Bruce cot in the United
States the point is these flat segments
represent the minimum average cost in
each country
it's just instead of making it a point
I'm making it up there's an amount of
production they can do with that average
cost I mean an average cost now let's
say world demand for cotton was 1
billion kilograms per year then what
would happen would be what I taught
there would be you would have Pakistan
competitors in Pakistan would compete ok
driving profits down to zero and price
would be 71 cents per kilogram now let's
say however demand for cotton is 5
billion kilograms per year
well now that intersects this supply
curve this is the world supply curve
is the supply curve at $1 71 so now US
producers or making zero profits because
their marginal cost our 71 the price
dollar 71 but what about producers in
Pakistan
they still make cotton they make the
first almost 2 billion kilos but they're
selling it $1 71 and their cost them 71
cents so they just made profits the
point is that if there are firms which
have rising costs and demand is high
enough that the high cost firms actually
producing that higher price means
profits for the low cost firm yeah that
could you could imagine those profits
could then have a feedback effect in
asset markets your and you could imagine
a long run in the very very very long
run as people buy land that could
dissipate the profits that's a good
point we'll come back to that but but
but no that's a very long run okay but
for now people have their land in
Pakistan and they're making their money
on it and so that becomes long-run
profits so long run profits can come
from heterogeneous costs if some firms
are particularly efficient in a multi
market firm those firms can make money
okay that's a second feature okay now
the third feature is in some sense the
most interesting which is input prices
may not be fixed and in fact input
prices input prices that inputs may have
an upward sloping supply there could be
an upward sloping supply for inputs
we've assumed input Pricer everywhere
fixed but that's not true and in a few
lectures we'll come and teach you about
that but for now let's recognize that
inputs may have an upward sloping supply
so let's go through that for couplets
before we stop let's take a mark in a
figure eight five okay
this is the market for labor now we've
only been doing markets for good so far
in this course and I'm sort of
shortcutting by jumping you here we'll
spend a lot more time on this graph but
the bottom line is this is a graph of
the amount of Labor supplied to the
market in this graph
people are now the suppliers because
they're supplying labor firms are the
demanders they're demanding labor so
what happens gives a supply curve of
Labor and let's assume it's upward slope
is what I mean by that is as the wage
goes up people want to work harder you
want to work harder as the wage goes up
so is it upward sloping supply it makes
sense right
upward supposing slaves labor now let's
imagine a firm suddenly wants to produce
more they used to produce little q1 now
they want to produce little q2 to do so
they need more workers that represents a
shift out in the demand for workers with
upward sloping supply what does that do
raises the wage if you want more workers
you've got to pay them more we didn't do
that before we assumed W as a constant
but imagine if to produce more you have
to pay more what does that do we see
that in Figure 86 now I used to produce
the market equilibrium used to be at
little point at Point E one with n ones
from n1 firms Bruce and q1 little q1 ok
so that point big e1 Big E big big
comedy one is little n1 there was n
firms producing little q1 units per firm
and they were making these profits their
profits were where price equals marginal
cost one now shifting to the left P
equals marginal cost one that little II
1 so they were producing where marginal
cost equals average cost so little q1 at
price p1 meant the firm's through Z a
little he won which was a zero profit
point ok now what happens now that now
the firm wants to produce more demand
goes up for a month to produce more it
wants to produce q2 you're in a new long
run I can live with n firms to n two
firms producing q2
well in that case okay now if you wanna
produce q2 you're gonna have to pay a
higher wage a higher wage means a higher
marginal average cost higher marginal
average costs means that you're now
producing at a higher price and
therefore the supply curve slopes upward
okay now this is very different one
thing to think about I'll let you go one
last thing to think about think about
the difference between this third case
in the other two cases in the other two
cases firms made profits in this case
firms still don't make profits so notice
that profits still zero but the supply
curves upward sloping so you don't need
positive profits to have an upward
sloping supply curve so let's stop there
give you a lot to think about and we
will come back I talked more about this
stuff on Wednesday